Once again, it's time to fire up the Mighty
Marvel rumor mill.
Pop culture website We Got This Covered is
reporting that its wily, ever-anonymous sources
have knowledge that Marvel Studios is eyeing
Dacre Montgomery, who portrayed Billy Hargrove
on the hit Netflix series Stranger Things,
to fill the role of Wolverine in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
Before we go any further, we feel compelled
to make a few things clear about this "breaking"
news.
First, WGTC is typically not a super-reliable
source of inside information.
While the website has fielded accurate rumor
reports in the past, it also has a pesky habit
of spreading absolute malarkey.
Plus, since no other media outlets are reporting
that Marvel wants the young Australian actor
for the role of Wolverine, the idea that these
folks are "breaking" anything but Dacre Montgomery
fans' hearts is pretty laughable.
"I have never felt such humor!"
Second, this isn't the first time Montgomery
has been connected to a Marvel role by the
fandom.
As recently as last summer, the same website
reported that he was being considered for
the part of Adam Warlock in James Gunn's upcoming
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3, for example.
We'll leave it to you to decide whether this
indicates that Marvel Studios is trying super-hard
to find the right role for the talented actor,
or that the internet's rumor mongers stepped
on their own feet with this one.
Third: if indeed Marvel is considering Montgomery
to take on the role of Wolverine which, again,
it could honestly go either way we're basically
as on board as you could get.
Ever since we got our hands on the actor's
insane Stranger Things audition tape, we've
wanted to see him land a major role in a superhero
franchise.
"OK, now listen: Why don't you put that away
before you shoot yourself in the foot with
it, OK?
You ain't got the sack to shoot a woodchuck."
We literally can't think of a better fit for
him than everyone's favorite cigar-chomping,
adamantium-infused mutant especially after
we saw our favorite digital artist BossLogic's
rendition of the guy!
As psyched as we would be to see Montgomery
take over as Logan in the MCU, WGTC's alleged
inside sources also put forth a small addendum
to the rumor which makes us doubt the whole
shebang.
According to them, Marvel brass are still
hopeful that they might be able to coax Hugh
Jackman, who held down the role for almost
20 years in the Fox Studios-produced X-Men
movies, to return.
Failing that, the sources say, the studio
would then be interested in talking to Montgomery.
Pardon us for saying so, but this doesn't
make a lick of sense.
When the X-Men and especially Wolverine finally
join the MCU, Marvel is going to want them
to be cast with actors who are capable of
playing their respective roles for as long
as possible.
At 51, this would in no way describe Jackman,
who in any event has stated plainly that he
is done with the role.
Montgomery is only 25, so if this rumor is
true, it indicates that Marvel just isn't
sure whether they want to go with an older
or a younger Logan.
We ask you: does this sound like Marvel Studios,
like, at all?
This is the studio which has a rough sketch
of its shared universe mapped out through
2028, according to head honcho Kevin Feige.
We're pretty sure that plans are well underway
for the introduction of the X-Men to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, and that no actors of
Jackman's vintage will be sought for the primary
roles.
It's worth mentioning that Montgomery has
previously appeared hesitant to star in comic
book movies in general.
In a 2019 video for GQ's "Actually Me" series,
in which the actor went undercover on social
media to take part in discussions about himself,
he encountered a fan who suggested that he'd
be perfect for the part of Jason Todd — AKA
Red Hood — the iconic Batman sidekick turned
villain.
Montgomery's response was pretty thoughtful.
He said, in part:
"I would really like to play outside of the
world that's so prominent, I guess, in cinemas
at the moment, which is just origin stories
of amazing superheroes that we love."
He added that he'd love to, quote, " … dive
into a different world that we don't know,
that we aren't...
given a lot of."
Whether it turns out that Montgomery's got
the gusto to play Ol' Canucklehead or not,
we'll be keeping both ears to the ground for
any news regarding the future of the X-Men
in the MCU — and, as always, we'll keep
you informed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.